there's nothing like a great TV finale
one conclusive episode which gives a
shows characters and stories not to
mention the viewers who've faithfully
followed along a truly satisfying
send-off
unfortunately however there are plenty
of finales often two really great shows
that just can't stick the landing from
controversial conclusions to all-out
storytelling disasters these episodes
ranked among the most frustrating TV
finales ever made The Sopranos a
prestige HBO hit which heralded the dawn
of televisions Golden Age The Sopranos
brought the medium to new heights
blurring the longstanding lines between
the small screen and large after six
seasons and countless twists and turns
only one question remains to round off
the show what would be the fate of Tony
Soprano the finales final scene is one
of TV's most notorious Tony whilst out
at dinner notices a man walk into the
restaurant is he just a fellow diner or
a hit man out for blood are any of the
other patrons of the restaurant out to
get him the tension builds as his family
arrives and sits at the table one by one
but just as the scene appears to be
moving towards the climax the screen
abruptly cuts to black
Tony's fate is left unresolved The
Sopranos ending is jarring to say the
least and while many appreciate its
subversive brilliance it's hard not to
empathize with anybody who doesn't
Dexter
showtimes flagship crime drama had
already fallen pretty far off the rails
by the time it came to an end at this
point the show had wandered into a
bizarre final storyline and managed to
botch the only good thread the show had
left to follow
Dexter's terrible secret being
discovered instead of any kind of
definitive ending for the character
Dexter fakes his own death and escapes
to Oregon where he begins working as a
truck driver it was a bizarre bitter and
inconclusive letdown for the few
remaining fans of a once-great show
Seinfeld
a precursor to some of today's most
popular comedies about gangs of horrible
people
Seinfeld built its brand on an
uncomfortable kind of humor led by
characters far more loathsome than your
typical protagonists in the process it
became one of televisions most iconic
and subversive shows the series finale
however is notorious for all the wrong
reasons
Seinfeld's final episode found Elaine
Jerry George and Kramer on trial for
laughing at a man who was being held at
gunpoint
during the trial every person they've
wronged over the course of the series
testifies against them putting into
perspective just how odious each
character is by the end of the episode
they're all in jail a popular series
ending with a glorified clip show was a
highly unusual move and the finale was
deeply divisive amongst fans even
Seinfeld himself admitted I sometimes
think we really shouldn't have even done
it very good very good
one year
How I Met Your Mother kind of spells it
all out in the title doesn't it no
matter how long the show ran how many
detours it took or how many characters
had followed it was always going to be
the tale of how Ted the protagonist met
the mother of his children as long as it
answered that question in a gripping and
believable fashion viewers were going to
be left happy
spoiler alert though they weren't rather
than take the satisfying route the
show's writers decided to tack on a
last-minute stinger explaining that the
mother passed away shortly before Ted
started telling the story to his kids
who insist that the whole time he's
actually been in love with his friend
Robin know this is a story about hires
totally in love with aunt Robin this was
a romantic pairing the show had
attempted earlier before Robin moved on
and married Neil Patrick Harris his
character Barney to make matters worse
the show's creators actually filmed a
happier ending - the whole death thing
and for some reason decided to go with
this one instead it could have been so
good True Blood when the entire premise
of your show revolves around a single
major choice a character has to make
you'd better make sure you wrap things
up in a satisfying manner to say True
Blood failed to do this is an
understatement Anna Paquin's Sookie
Stackhouse the small-town waitress who
finds herself wrapped up in the world of
the supernatural
spends the whole series trying to decide
where her heart truly lies is it with
Bill the vampiric Southern gentleman or
with Eric the icy Nordic vampire Lord or
maybe she'll end up with Alcide the
jacked werewolf construction worker
Sookie as it turned out ended up with
none of the above Alcide and Bill are
both dead by the time the show has come
to an end while Eric has just moved on
instead she ends up with some human dude
viewers predictably weren't happy can
you blame them penny dreadful penny
dreadfuls finale was in many ways
actually pretty great it wrapped up
every character arc and convincingly
resolved most of the show's plot lines
and with such a large ensemble cast it
was no easy task so why was this episode
so frustrating because nobody knew it
was a finale some controversy exists as
to just why penny dreadful ended when it
did but the important thing to know here
is that the show's third season was
never marketed as its last
it was only after the final shot had
faded out in the words the end appeared
on the screen that viewers realized
they'd just seen their last episode ever
for the show's many die-hard fans and
followers it was a painful and sudden
demise which considering the show in
question does seem like a pretty apt way
to end things
[Music]